now to report you'll see first only on
CBS mornings it could have a major
impact on the seafood that we eat a
wildlife protection watch group says
Watchdog group rather says Lobster and
some other fishing is not sustainable
right now and that Lobster menus and
lobster on the menu should be avoided
the goal is not to protect the lobster
though but the heavily endangered right
whale species and Tracy shows us what
this could mean for an already strained
fishing industry
in New England a long holiday weekend
pairs well with lobster rolls but now
the billion dollar Lobster industry is
reeling from essentially being
blacklisted New England is lobster I
mean there's no question about that it
would have a huge huge detrimental
effect on this area
Fred penny has been catching Lobster off
the coast of Massachusetts for more than
50 years he's angry that 14 Fisheries
are now labeled Red by Seafood watch a
widely respected world leader in Seafood
rankings meaning consumers and
businesses are being advised to avoid
them besides Lobster this includes all
East Coast snow crab and several species
of flounder and Atlantic Cod the
designation doesn't actually ban eating
or selling the fish but can lead
restaurants and grocery stores to drop
them from menus or label them
unsustainable if the restaurants put up
a sign that say Don't eat lobsters
people are not going to come in and eat
lobsters that's my concern the problem
isn't the fish it's the fishing gear
Seafood watch and government agencies
say vertical lines and ropes are a
leading cause of injury and death for
the critically endangered North Atlantic
right whale its population has shrunk by
30 percent in just the past decade and
there are now fewer than 340 of them
alive no one
wants to know that their appetite for
seafood is driving a species to
Extinction
you know so what secret watch is doing
is putting a flag in the ground right
now and saying there's an important
issue let's pay attention Jennifer
Kimberly with seafood watch says if an
industry changes its fishing practices
it can find a way off this list but the
New England Lobster industry is already
being battered by climate change
last year we visited the Gulf of Maine
which is warming faster than 99 percent
of the Earth's oceans warming water is
causing some fish species including
Lobster to migrate North my primary
fishery is lobster we met lobsterman
Steve train who has started to also Farm
kelp otherwise known as seaweed because
the lobster catch is increasingly
unpredictable I mean does this feel like
a lifeline and right now we're heavily
dependent on one resource so if there is
a turn in the fishery there needs to be
something else especially now that the
lobster industry is rated red for CBS
mornings I'm Ben Tracy